[Música]
i
hola y bienvenidos a europa hoy el
programa de actualidad europea de france
24 en español yo soy este dakar o desde
el parlamento europeo en bruselas es un
placer saludarles en el programa de hoy
abordamos la situación económica en
europa se acerca la región y el mundo a
una nueva recesión antes de pasar al
debate hacemos un repaso a la situación
económica actual la guerra en ucrania
que estalló a finales de febrero empeoró
las perspectivas económicas mundiales la
inflación está marcando récords en la
unión europea y el resto de países del
mundo sobre todo en temas de alimentos y
aumento de precios de la energía lo cual
dificulta que las familias puedan llegar
a final de mes y el panorama económico
empeora al añadírsele las consecuencias
de las sanciones impuestas a rusia el
incremento en los tipos de interés tanto
en eeuu como por parte del banco central
europeo y un ligero retroceso en el
crecimiento económico de china debido en
gran parte al cierre de algunas de sus
compañías por su política de kobe cero
provoca incertidumbre entre los
inversores ante el temor de una recesión
la directora general del fondo monetario
internacional kristalina georgieva
admitió un escenario en los próximos
meses y no descarta una recesión tampoco
la ocde sin embargo las instituciones y
ministros de finanzas europeos se
muestran confiados en que se pueda
evitar siempre y cuando rusia no corte
por completo el suministro del gas a los
ciudadanos europeos aunque bruselas no
es tan optimista y según sus cálculos
estos riesgos si podrían causar el
decrecimiento la comisión europea por el
momento cree que podrá sortear se la
inquietud gracias al plan de
recuperación post pandemia que inyecta
dinero público y privado en los países
y para entender a qué se puede enfrentar
la unión europea en los próximos meses
contamos con los eurodiputados y
economistas jonás fernández del grupo
socialdemócrata bienvenido a jonás en
ellos y con luis garicano del grupo
renovar europa bienvenidos muchas
gracias muchas gracias a los dos que
estáis aquí primero todo me gustaría
empezar con una pregunta hay que temer a
una nueva recesión yo creo que si el
banco central europeo nos vio un
escenario que llamaron de dinero
pesimista en el que estamos asistiendo
estanflación y yo creo que los los
argumentos necesarios se hace el que es
el escenario están ahí básicamente yo
creo que hemos de partir de que lo más
probable es que nos corten la energía
del gas por parte de putin esos
ministros franceses acaba de de insistir
en esta posibilidad y con ese corte de
energía pues teníamos una subida fuerte
de los costes de energía y una caída del
pib con lo cual yo creo que ese
escenario
con terol p hablaba de 6% inflación 2
puntos de caída de que el año que viene
es perfectamente 2% de crecimiento pero
bueno sin duda ese es un escenario
posible y probablemente a la vista de la
evolución de las noticias
fundamentalmente en temas energéticos
ese escenario gana probabilidad pero es
cierto que en esos momentos el escenario
central sigue siendo una tasa de
crecimiento positiva cuando una
inflación obviamente más alta de las que
veníamos observando en el pasado pero
pero lejos de la estanflación estamos
con con tasas de crecimiento positivas
en el escenario pesimista del bc tasas
de crecimiento positivas inflaciones
altas en cualquier caso es verdad que el
escenario es susceptible de empeorar
porque los elementos que hay encima de
la mesa como decía apuntan en esa
dirección y por lo tanto hay que estar
muy muy muy alertas podríamos decir
estamos hablando de una crisis
economía una posible crisis económica
derivada por una crisis energética
recientemente hemos sabido que el
gobierno francés quiere nacionalizar la
eléctrica edf alemania también quiere
salvar a su gerente energético un híper
nos estamos acercando a esta tendencia
de nacionalizar compañías energéticas
como ocurrió en la anterior crisis en
que se rescataron a los bancos por
ejemplo no es yo fui muy crítico con la
que rescates porque no hay parecen que
se rescate a dos accionistas yo creo que
habrá veces que una compañía se hunda
porque ha prometido unos precios que no
puede cumplir en el caso de un híper
de una manera muy errónea porque se
apoyaba en una certidumbre de energía
rusa que no existía y que debería
haberlo sabido con lo cual yo entiendo
que el gobierno alemán pueda tenerles
que rescatar puede ser si hace falta
para mantener el suministro puede ser
pero de ninguna manera me parece que eso
incluya a rescatar a sus accionistas es
decir
los accionistas compran unas acciones
esperando un retorno si les va bien pues
ganan y si les va mal pierden lo que no
puede ser es que si la empresa va bien
ganó y si va mal me rescatan eso no
puede ser qué es lo que pasó durante
crisis financiera con muchos bancos como
recordamos citibank tumaco americano muy
grande un año después del rescate ahí lo
mismo una aseguradora un año de rescate
estaba dando buenos millonarios porque
bueno les habían salvado la piel del
gobierno y luego ya volvieron a ganar
dinero
nos acercamos a esto a rescatar ahora
energéticas cuando yo creo que el caso
por ejemplo de edf en francia es más un
rescate que una nacionalización
podríamos decir no sí sí sí nos evoca
algo las palabras rescate y
nacionalización en cualquier caso es
bueno pues parece que el sector
energético está en el centro de la
crisis probablemente vamos a ver cortes
de suministro llevamos tiempo peleando
por aumentar las sanciones y va a ser va
a ser la otra parte de quién es quién
quien realmente acabe bloqueando las las
ventas de gas a europa muy probablemente
y en ese caso tenemos un sector
industrial energético pero también
industrial muy tocado que además tiene
conexiones con el sector financiero de
alemania es decir el núcleo económico de
alemania
esas medianas empresas familiares
industriales con costes de la energía
muy barata pero además con cosas de
financiación muy barata porque se
financian fundamentalmente a través de
eso en que no tienen propósito de
beneficio y por lo tanto hay una
transferencia de los beneficios
implícitos del sector financiero al
sector industrial que hasta ahora ha
tenido pues no ha generado los superávit
por cuenta corriente desde hace muchos
muchos años y ya estamos en números en
saldos negativos en la balanza comercial
por lo tanto el sector industrial
energético está en el centro pero como
siempre el sector financiero está muy
cerquita de del problema y veremos a ver
si solamente vamos a observar
intervenciones en el sector energético o
si pudiera haber
intervenciones también en sector
financiero habéis comentado la inflación
ahora está en el centro de la
preocupación de muchos ciudadanos el
banco central europeo anunció una subida
de los tipos de interés pero ya habíamos
visto que la reserva federal se ha
adelantado algo que está subida de tipos
de interés que ha anunciado el banco
central no se producía desde hace más de
diez años es algo positivo pesar de que
esto también tiene una repercusión
también en los bolsillos los ciudadanos
con los positivos en el sentido de que
es necesario
quizás lo comentar ya y lucha contra la
inflación bueno ese sentido explosivo
del anuncio no han hecho de momento lo
que de hecho ha sido hablar pero yo creo
que lo más
la aplicación más importante es negativa
porque supone que tenemos la inflación
fuera de control
que la gente va a tener que pagar más
por sus hipotecas y no tener que pagar
más por sus préstamos más por los
préstamos y que sobre todo y esta es la
consecuencia más complicada para todos
nosotros que los países más endeudados
sufren un golpe desproporcionado con que
su vida pequeña de tipos a quien debe
mucho dinero le afecta mucho y convierte
esa subida en un riesgo para su
sostenibilidad esto es lo que lo que
vemos ahora ya hemos visto en italia -
en españa pero también lo que vemos es
una percepción en los mercados de que
ante la subida de tipos hay países que
están que son muy vulnerables este es
realmente la mayor incertidumbre hemos
hecho lo suficiente durante estos diez
años para que nuestra unión monetaria a
nuestro niño económico nuestro euro
gente sabe que compartimos una moneda de
dos países europeos
sea lo suficientemente sólido para que
bueno pues hoy los tipos suben y bajan y
esto es la vida para que eso no tenga
consecuencias
digamos expansivas que se multiplican o
por el contrario la falta de un seguro
de depósitos bueno europeo esas cosas
puede llevar a que una subida de tipos
deje algunos países muy tocados y yo me
inclino por la segunda opción creo que
no hemos hecho suficiente y creo que el
escenario de subida de tipos y de fin de
las políticas de compras de activos
puede ser muy peligroso por algunos
países buenos hechos no se ha hecho lo
suficiente como dice luisa ahora vemos
que por ejemplo el euro está totalmente
equiparado ahora mismo al dólar algo que
no ocurría en 20 años sí bueno veremos a
ver cuál es la respuesta de política
monetaria del bce no porque siendo
cierto que muy probablemente en el
inicio de este shock está aún una subida
de los costes realmente al inicio de
este proceso inflacionario en mi opinión
fue claramente una cuestión de oferta es
verdad que con el tiempo se puede ir
infiltrándose a la demanda si hay
si el incremento de los precios
energéticos se condensa se internaliza
en el proceso de fijación de precios
pero pero bueno las situaciones es
complicada no la política monetaria
tendrá que acompañar aún sabiendo que no
solamente la política monetaria podrá
acomodar la inflación porque si creemos
que solamente el bc está al cargo de
esta responsabilidad
sin duda vamos a un escenario de
recesión y de inflación es aún elevadas
y por lo tanto creo que es necesario que
las políticas fiscales de los de los
países se acomoden a esta nueva
situación y probablemente en mi opinión
y ya que estamos en el parlamento sería
oportuno yo creo que enmarcar un proceso
de pacto de rentas a nivel europeo no no
sí obviamente las competencias son son
nacionales los agentes sociales juegan
en la arena nacional es ahí donde está
la responsabilidad pero en la crisis de
lakovic la respuesta fiscal fue una
respuesta fiscal nacional lo cierto es
los avales los garantías respuestas
nacionales amparadas en un marco europeo
y yo creo que en la medida en que la
política monetaria no es no va a ser
suficiente
estaría bien que a nivel europeo hubiera
decir un cierto una cierta atmósfera
política que ayudará a avanzar en ese
pacto de rentas en nuestro país y en el
resto porque realmente la inflación está
bastante más alta en otros países aparte
del nuestro y probablemente ese entorno
político institucional comunitario que
ha ayudado a orientar las políticas
nacionales de cada uno de los países
pues quizás se podría quizás se podría
hacer algo en estos momentos casi nos
hemos quedado sin tiempo pero quiero
hacer una pregunta hemos sufrido una
crisis económica una caída del pib
histórica con la pandemia ahora rusia
invade a ucrania y estamos teniendo a
consecuencia también claramente
económica también nos acercamos un poco
a esto a tener crisis cíclicas en un
mundo cada vez más incierto
la red es caro nos enfrentamos a lo que
algunos han llamado napoli crisis
existen muchas dimensiones tenemos la
crisis a medio y largo plazo tenemos la
crisis más grave que es el calentamiento
global que se va a estar así de fondo
durante próximas décadas tenemos también
una posible con problemas en el euro
quizás si no conseguimos resolverlos y
si esto se complica a medio plazo y a
corto plazo tenemos la guerra la crisis
energética en la pandemia hidroven hemos
acabado entonces efectivamente es un
entorno en el que la incertidumbre es
muy grande y que las herramientas
europeas para responder nuestros
suficientes no obtenemos un presupuesto
europeo verdadero no tenemos un
seguro de puesto es europeo no tenemos
capacidad para tomar decisiones de
pública exterior sólo por unanimidad
entonces nos encontramos una situación
en la que nuestra capacidad de acción y
los retos los que nos enfrentamos no
están a la altura el uno del otro y
entonces bueno yo espero que como pasó
con la pandemia a la que te referías
antes
europa se ponga a la altura de este
problema en este momento y se dote de
sus instrumentos
muchísimas gracias a los dos luis jonás
nos hemos quedado sin tiempo a ustedes
les esperamos en el próximo programa de
europa hoy gracias por ver france24 en
español
[Música]